No
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my marvel Wandavision episode 2 video there
were a whole bunch of easter eggs they moved into
the 1960s so we'll break it all down if you're
new to the channel i'm doing videos for all the
episodes so be sure to subscribe to get everything
we're going to have marvel episodes almost every
week all year long we're also doing a disney plus
giveaway for memberships all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your favorite
wtf moment from the episode on the video careful
for spoilers if you have not seen the episode yet
i'm going to number this a little bit differently
just because there's so much stuff happening in
the first couple of episodes but the episode
begins with that same brand new marvel phase 4
intro scene that they tune a little bit
differently for the Wandavision series they'll
probably do versions of this for all the different
marvel phase 4 series like when we get to the loki
episodes the falcon and winter soldier episodes
they'll get their own version of a special intro
scene like this but now we're into the 1960s it's
sort of a dick van dyke bewitch style episode they
start with that scene of the double beds i did a
video a little while ago because they released the
scene a couple days early scarlet witch is kind of
doing her samantha bewitch thing using her powers
to turn on and off the light then they start
hearing the banging sound and vision starts to act
really comedically kind of like the dick van dyke
character vision did you use your night vision so
you can kind of see because during this era of
television and during that particular tv show
the way that they wrote the jokes were a little
bit different from the way they wrote the jokes
during the i love lucy episode during episode 1.
so the dialogue the jokes the way that they filmed
the episodes everything about each of these things
is meant to be period-specific as if the show was
being made during these different decades most
of you probably guessed that the banging that
they keep hearing throughout the episode they
keep referencing it later in the episode too
like vision starts talking about security later
in the episode during that neighborhood watch
scene and then they finally pay it off at the end
of the episode it's about the sword agents trying
to bang their way into the alternate reality
because if you've seen the trailers you notice
that there's this giant dome of red energy around
the neighborhood they haven't completely explained
how this alternate reality was created only that
this looks like scarlet witch's energy and she's
the one that seems like she has god level powers
inside here so like she's controlling everything
but obviously it's much more complicated than
that we get a brand new version of the intro
scene that's done like the bewitched tv show
with all the jokes about their powers vision
phasing through the walls in the shower because he
doesn't need a shower he phases through the closet
because he also doesn't need to put clothes on
he just changes his appearance to make it look
like he's wearing different clothes when he phases
through the floorboards though you notice a couple
big easter eggs the helmet there actually belongs
to the character grim reaper from the comics he's
actually the brother of wonder man huge comic
book deep cut for vision's original origin story
obviously we don't really have wonder man in the
mcu right now but wonder man's brain patterns in
the comics and personality were used to create
vision originally to make him feel like a real
human you could also think of this spiderweb here
as a spider-man reference because the director
of wandavision said that he was working with the
director of spider-man 3 john watts to help with
the continuity that's more of the multiverse big
marvel phase 4 overplot though so i'll talk about
those easter eggs when we see them in later
episodes Wandavision is meant to help set up
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness spider-man
3 and the marvel version of the x-men characters
that we'll be seeing in marvel phase 4 marvel
phase 5 the eventual rebooted x-men film that's
why they're doing the house of m storyline and
obviously they're doing it in a very trippy legion
tv show style way where nobody knows quite what's
real and what's fake you also notice there's some
bones in the floorboards here too you could
also think of that as a callback to the joke
from episode 1 about vision having skeletons
quote unquote in his closet i don't really have
a skeleton then they go to the grocery store
there's easter eggs all over the background in
here you actually see monica rambo's character for
the first time she shows up in the actual episode
pretty soon but up on the logos behind here on
the wall you see wonder and it's cereal of some
kind obviously that's just another reference to
wonder man you see bova milk because bova was
the character that helped save scarlet witch and
quicksilver as babies giving them to their foster
parents the maximoffs he was working for the high
evolutionary tooth there's a lot of rumors that
he could actually show up during guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 and he's the character
who created rocket but bova milk bovine cow
cows milk you get the reference the anti-a
cat sign there also probably another reference
to act of the harkness in the comics you also
notice as the car is driving by all the neighbors
and they're all chanting and singing in unison
because scarlet witch is kind of controlling this
reality they sort of pay that off at the end of
the episode too when things glitch out but then
swing back to normal you also notice that agnes
is holding that bunny rabbit the bunny rabbit
shows up a couple times during the episode so
it seems like it has some more significance we
start the episode though with vision practicing
his talent show obviously all this magic is
referenced to dr strange there's also another
big doctor strange easter egg later in the
episode the pin that monica rambo is wearing
is a doctor strange portal which is just another
reference to that obviously we're expecting more
doctor strange easter eggs in the later episodes
as well you notice that the box that he's going
to be using as part of his magic talent show has
the picture of the mind stone on the front of it
what's in the box everybody post all the memes
what is in the box tell me what's in the box
and because a lot of this energy is dick van dyke
even though they're doing a lot of bewitch stuff
and she's kind of like samantha scarlet wish also
very much looks like mary tyler moore the way her
outfit looks the way she acts the way they do her
hair but then vision leaves to go to the local
towns watch to discuss the noise from last night
remember this is a serialized plot so even though
the miss on scene of the episodes changes quite
a bit through the decades of different sitcoms
there is this over plot of the sword agents trying
to break in more and more until eventually the
end of the episode 1 of them finally does it the
episode goes a little twilight zone though when
she hears the banging sound again and it starts to
zoom in on her face like she's starting to realize
the reality is breaking around her like she kind
of seems like she's drunk the kool-aid and really
believes in the lie of what's going on around her
but there are a couple scenes later in the episode
that make it seem like she knows that this is
not real i'm not here to hurt anyone i'm not
trying to hurt anyone but the helicopter that she
finds in the bushes is in color that's the first
sign that something is really really wrong it has
a sword logo on it and it's modern day technology
it's also the red and yellow iron man colors as
well the mcu sword acronym actually stands for
sentient weapon observation and response team so
it sounds like within the mcu nick fury creates
sword to monitor super powered people which
will also include mutants eventually the x-men
characters much bigger threats from outer space
like the celestials eventually galactus once
we get to our fantastic four movies we're just
getting the teaser right now so we'll learn more
about what sword has been doing this whole time
but it's all tied to that nick fury sword space
station that we saw in the spider-man far from
home post-credits scenes then agnes surprises her
very ominously saying it's the star of the show
and the way that she says it too the way that she
performs that dialogue makes it sound like she's
really messing with scarlet witch during this
and obviously in the other trailers when she's
in the halloween witch costume she's messing with
vision as well telling him that he's really dead
so however scarlet witch originally came to this
alternate reality and created it with her powers i
think that agnes or agatha harkness had something
to do with that you get a better look at the
pin that she wears throughout all the different
decades too she has that during the first episode
too but you don't really see it close up till
episode 2 here it's hard to tell what the figures
on it are there's three different figures it looks
like a scythe it could be a reference to the grim
reaper it could be a reference to something else
we'll probably get more easter eggs for this later
on but then we meet the antagonist of the episode
dottie in her gang of neighborhood rotary club
thugs they have all this comedy about scarlet
witch trying to fit in with them even though she
totally does not fit in with them she said maybe
i should just be myself and agnes who kind of
snorts at that idea please don't do that obviously
another wink is the fact that please don't be
yourself because you have special powers you're an
avenger when they have those lines of dialogue the
devil is in the details and that's not the only
place he is obviously that's probably a reference
to mephisto because he's such a big part of
scarlet witch's children's backstory in the comics
and this episode is all about her getting pregnant
most of the episode references children in
some way they keep saying the word children
talking about children but you notice that there
aren't a lot of children around the neighborhood
until she gets pregnant later those children or
billy and tommy from the comics you actually see
them in some of the other trailer footage they
get much older through the decades that's one
of the reasons why they're doing this whole tropy
thing of the sitcoms through the different decades
so that they can age up their children to
teenagers older by the end of the series
and they can go on to do young avengers projects
another marvel phase 4 series if you don't know
about billy and tommy wiccan and speed i'll talk
about them in future episodes when they actually
start showing up and we see their powers start
to manifest but they are x-men characters so
this is mutants coming to the mcu through house
of m we also finally get to meet monica rambo in
the flesh for the first time like i said her pin
is a ring portal like dr strange's ring portals
she calls herself geraldine but she also says
she has no idea what she's doing here like she
genuinely has no idea even though we know that
she's a sword agent so it sounds like when people
break into this reality or they get sucked in
somehow their mind gets altered so that they fit
whatever the scenario is based on scarlet
witch's desires like when she starts to lose
control people start to realize wait a minute who
are you what am i doing here what's going on here
vision meets with the club and they have all these
funny communist jokes because this is still the
1960s this is still hardcore cold war era they
continue to tell jokes about him not eating food
then he eats the gum and they turn it into
a vision gets drunk big comedy bit for the
rest of the episode they even do the old-timey
cartoon version of the gum literally gumming up
his works so to speak even though you think that
his vibranium technology would be so advanced that
something like gum wouldn't be able to hurt it you
have to remember that because this is an alternate
reality being controlled by scarlet witch things
don't obey the normal laws of physics or reality
when you have that big scarlet witch versus dottie
scene i was just waiting for her to lose it on
dottie but she doesn't quite take it that far i
think that happens a little bit in later episodes
like she slowly starts to go crazier and crazier
as she starts to lose her control of the reality
around them and it starts to crack and crumble
then just as it seems like she's about to lose
it you hear the sword agents on the radio trying
to contact her and it's randall park's voice as
jimmy woo you remember him from ant-man and the
wasp wanda what's going on who's doing this to you
remember at this point the sword agents have no
idea what's going on what created this and what's
happening to her inside here they don't know
that she's the person that's actually doing this
so it's not until later in the episode when you
see her say no to the sword agent and rewind time
in the reality that you find out that really she's
kind of like the antagonist like she's the villain
of this series and the protagonist at the same
time then the fake reality sort of snaps back
to what it's supposed to be and dottie forgets
about her bloody red hand in the fact that it's
in color we get our next commercial and it's
obviously a big baron von strucker avengers
age of ultron reference with a hydra logo on the
watch the phrase strucker will make time for you
is obviously a big callback to her origin story
with the mind stone during that captain america
winter soldier post credit scene and quicksilver's
origin story as well but then vision comes back
super drunk off the gum and scarlet witch tries
to explain to him about what's going on with the
helicopter but they get roped into this big talent
show so she doesn't have time and because vision
is so drunk he basically tells everyone through
his dialogue his performance what's actually
happening inside this reality it's all fake it's
all an illusion we're going to deceive you but the
real funny moments of the bit though are scarlet
witch trying to chase after him at each turn where
he's sort of spoiling everything he's being like
tom holland big spectacular spoiler man giving
away the secret every time he uses his powers
like he floats in the air or he lifts the piano
she uses her reality warping powers to hide that
fact and make it seem like it's all fake until
the one guy is like wait a minute that was my
mother's piano that's not fake then they have the
joke about monica rambo being magicked into the
box what's in the box because it's definitely not
scarlet witch they win comedy performance of the
year because everyone is just so flabbergasted by
everything that they did saving the day and then
monica rambo also questions the nature of reality
again how'd you magic me from backstage into the
box how did that work they go home they start
referencing their children and suddenly realize
out of nowhere scarlet witch is like six months
pregnant the twins aren't really born until the
1970s episode till a little bit later because you
don't see the larger baby versions of themselves
till the 1980s when it looks like it goes to
family ties but then they hear that banging sound
again and it goes super dark twilight zone as the
camera zooms in they go outside and you see the
sword agent covered in bees climbing through the
sewer drain scarlet witch says no and rewinds
reality back to this moment with them thinking
about their children when all of a sudden vision
starts turning into color around them and the
house starts changing to the 1970s brady bunch
version of the house the frame fades out again
with the same type of outro scene in jimmywoo's
voice calling out over the radio wanda wanda can
you hear me who's doing this to you and the real
tv screen in present day in the main mcu reality
with the sword agent monitoring what's going on
like i said i think this is going to be darcy's
character from the thor movies but i know a lot
of you are wondering who is this character and why
were there bees all over his hazmat suit obviously
it's a sword agent because he has a sword logo on
his back i think this is just one of the sword
agents himself the reason why he probably had
bees all around him swarming is because sometimes
military teams will use bees as bomb detectors and
remember jimmy wu the sword agents they have
no idea what's going on in here they think
that somebody a villain is trapping scarlet
witch and doing something terrible to her
so they're trying to break in to save her without
knowing that she's the one that's doing this
in the moment where she says no and rewinds things
sort of gives away her hand she's the one that's
actually controlling all this doing it to herself
and to the people of the town but obviously the
big thing here is leading up to the birth of
her twin children the x-men from the comics the
first legit x-men in the mcu what'll also probably
start happening in the future episodes as well too
is we'll see more footage from outside the reality
in regular present day mcu i think a lot of people
were thrown off by the first episode in most of
the second episode because so much of it was in
black and white and they just jumped into the
scenario without explaining how they got in here
that's just because of the way they want to reveal
what's actually going on inside this quote-unquote
reality this very matrix-like simulation style
version of reality but if you spotted any big
easter eggs in the episode that i didn't mention
in the video just write them below in the comments
my Wandavision episode 3 video will post next
friday all the episodes will post once per
week from now on there are nine episodes total
that's going to take us right up to the premiere
of falcon and winter soldier then we'll get all
the falcon and winter soldier episodes the black
widow movie then the loki episodes so on and so
forth so while you wait for everything click here
for my Wandavision episode 1 video and click
here for that brand new black panther 2 teaser
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!